l'initiative n'en finit plus d'agiter la
gauche à une semaine de la primaire
populaire les organisateurs revendiquent
plus de 300 mille inscrits problème la
majorité des candidats refusent d'y
participer alors quelle légitimité on en
parle avec mon invité ce soir bonsoir
nicolas poisson bonjour monsieur clavel
vous êtes l'un des promoteurs de la
primaire populaire dans valoir militants
de cette primaire populaire on jette
d'abord un coup d'oeil au calendrier
donc pour cette première populaire
inscriptions jusqu'à dimanche soir sur
le site primaire populaire point fr avec
un vote en ligne du 27 au 30 janvier la
proclamation du vainqueur dans la foulée
sept candidats sont sur la ligne de
départ anna haag aides porteraient anne
hidalgo et yannick jadot pierre
larrouturou charlotte marchandises jean
luc mélenchon et christiane taubira donc
le but de cette primaire c'est de
rassembler la gauche derrière un
candidat unique pour la présidentielle
initiative en dehors des partis qui sont
les militants de la primaire populaire
alors les militants de la primaire
populaire il faut bien se dire que ce
sont des citoyens j'ai envie de dire de
base de base et pas péjoratif du tout
c'est un mouvement qui est 100% citoyens
gay 100% indépendant qui n'est financée
par nulle autre personne que ceux qui
veulent bien donner généreusement
et donc c'est le mérite de cette
primaire populaire c'est que c'est un
mouvement qui vient d'en bas qui vient
de la base et la légitimité dans ce
mouvement de la primaire populaire et
dans ce vote qui va arriver c'est qu'il
ya quand même un sondage et lab opinion
2020 qui est sorti fin fin décembre aux
environs du solstice et qui nous dit
qu'il ya 85 % des sympathisants de
gauche qui veulent une union et qui
veulent une candidature unique pour la
gauche pour les présidentielles à venir
une primaire qui plutôt du coup une
investiture avec puisque a pas de débat
entre les candidats avec un mode de
désignation inédit expliquez nous alors
ce mode de désignation effectivement
c'est assez innovant
il faut savoir et leur rendre hommage
que c'est ça va être un jugement qui va
se faire au vote majoritaire et cette
méthode là elle est invitée à inventer
pardon pas michel balinski et rida
laraki jeu par un écorché leurs noms qui
sont deux grands chercheurs français
mathématicien est donc cette méthode
elle permet déjà à travers la primaire
populaire de donner une idée de
l'évolution de la démocratie qu'on veut
à travers cette personne on donne des
appréciations à ces salles président 1
absolument il va y avoir des mentions
qui vont être données donc là dans le
cadre de ce vote majoritaire il n'y a
pas de vote compte il n'y a pas de vote
pour donc on est vraiment à donner une
mention on vote pour chacun des
candidats avec des mentions qui vont de
très bien bien assez bien passable ou
encore insuffisant et donc à la fin on a
un gagnant une gaine occasion une
gagnante à travers une mention
majoritaire qui en fait la médiane de
tout ça alors les parties vous accuse de
vouloir leur tordre le bras puisque les
candidats n'ont pas donné leur accord
tout cas pas tous pour participer la
france insoumise et jean luc mélenchon
par exemple vous demande de retirer son
nom de tous les supports physiques et
numériques anne hidalgo yannick jadot
vous tourne le dos aussi quoi qu'il
arrive cela ne reconnaîtront pas le
résultat est ce que c'est une primaire
pour rien c'est pas une primaire pour
rien parce que cette primaire elle s'est
faite avec des militants qui viennent de
tous les partis il ya un socle d'idées
commun auquel ce qui est adhère donc les
quatre candidats qui ont choisi vraiment
de reconnaître cette primaire populaire
et d'y participer et de respecter les
règles il s'engage absolument à
respecter ce socle commun qui a été
construit par des citoyens lambda j'ai
envie de dire et aussi des militants de
tous les partis dont europe ecologie les
verts explique sans ambages le ps cette
primaire populaire avec trois cent mille
inscrits à la fin si on a qui veulent
considérer ça comme un sondage jean luc
mélenchon l'a dit dernièrement via un
grand bien lui fasse mais on peut pas
enlever que cette primaire populaire il
ya un point essentiel pour demain pour
notre avenir de tous les françaises et
tous les français c'est une nouvelle
république et cette nouvelle république
elle est très importante puisque tout le
monde aura à coeur de trouver un juste
équilibre entre la participation et la
représentation
cette rumeur populaire elle est vraiment
l'émanation de cette volonté populaire
de participer davantage à la vie
politique et donc on peut pas renier
cette démarche merci beaucoup nicolas
poissons que les résultats le 30 janvier
à ce ca et et les militants comme vous
encartés ou non un peuvent encore
s'inscrire en ligne merci beaucoup
absolument merci merci beaucoup dit que
la poisse aux